joe biden comes here without a deal
sealed with congress backing his climate
change program and to a g20 that's
divided on the issue
this is what's at stake though
extraordinary floods in sicily a timely
reminder of the urgency of the moment
in the scene straight out of a disaster
movie this week
in balmy sunshine world leaders arrived
in rome for the g20 summit and to a
stern lecture from the un security
general about their failure so far
even if recent pledges were clear and
credible
and there are serious questions about
some of them
we are still careening towards climate
catastrophe
and the best case scenario
temperatures will still rise well above
2 degrees
and that is a disaster
on his flight here prime minister boris
johnson issued twin warnings on climate
change and covert 19 calling on g20
partners to vaccinate the world by the
end of next year
but ahead of the 26 climate summit in
glasgow international efforts are losing
momentum not least because america's
president is struggling to deliver on
his agenda
joe biden comes here still needing to
convince allies that america really is
back and leading the free world again
not least on climate change the g20 has
to prove it is united enough to tackle
the climate crisis
i'm the only irishman you've ever met
who's never had a drink
joe biden shared a presence and jokes
with the pope but comes here without a
deal sealed at home on his climate
change program
[Music]
doubts over cop and the g20 are helping
fuel protests ahead of the summits greta
tunberg joining activists in london
and in rome thousands are preparing to
march on the g20 summit among those
gathering at this climate camp there
seemed a growing sense of despair you
have to act now and you have to change
the economic system
otherwise
otherwise it's going to be a disaster
they're really not doing anything it's
getting worse by the minute and
literally we have very few years to come
to stop this we have to stop it right
now
tomorrow is already late every day is
late and
they've been doing they really have been
doing nothing
from rome to glasgow your solutions are
the problem says this banner
leaders have two days here and two weeks
in scotland to prove that wrong
dominic waghorn sky news row